هل تصف ما تراه
من حيث الإصابات بأنه جرائم
ضد الإنسانية أه بالنسبة لي أستطيع أن أقول
ذلك بالتأكيد أقصد ماذا ماذا
كيف تفسر هل تعرف
ملعب الناس أو الأطفال يلعبون في
الملعب أو البقاء في المدرسة  أو أه
تعلمين يتعالجون في المستشفيات
فيقتلون أو أو ينامون في
منازلهم ويقتلون
بلا سبب يعني بالنسبة لي لا أرى
أي سبب لكن من وجهة نظري أه على
الأقل كوزارة  الصحة
لا أنا من
حق المريض أن يعيش من
حق المريض أن يحصل على فرصة للحصول على
العلاج كيف ترى
مريض مصاب بالسرطان وعمره 5 سنوات
أو ست سنوات ولا يتلقى
العلاج الكيميائي أه فيه  أربعة أسابيع أو خمسة
أسابيع ماذا تفعل ماذا تفعل كيف تسمي ذلك كيف
تسمي ذلك الحادث كيف
تسميه كيف
تعرف أن هناك طفل حديث الولادة يحتاج إلى
أجهزة تهوية وانقطعت عنها
الكهرباء وهم  نفاد الغاز ونفاد
الدواء
وأخبروني أنهم يحاولون وضع ثلاثة
نيوات في حاضنة واحدة، هل تصدق
ذلك وأرسلوا لي صورًا لذلك
لأنه ليس لديهم أي شيء آخر
يفعلونه، لذا وضعوا  أطفال ثلاثة منهم في
حاضنة واحدة لأنه ليس لديهم
الكثير من مصدر الطاقة لدعمهم
وعلى الرغم من أنهم بدأوا في
فقدان هؤلاء الأطفال حديثي الولادة ويريدون
إخراجهم كيف تسمي ذلك كيف
تسمي ذلك مع  الأطفال
من مستشفى ألفا ما هو الجدول الزمني
من حيث إدخالهم إلى مصر ومن
يملي هذا الجدول الزمني وكيف
يمكنك التدخل للأسف هذا
ليس في أيدينا أعني كما أخبرتك أن
سيارة الإسعاف لدينا الآن كما نتحدث تنتظر
في الحدود جاهزون لنقلهم على
الفور حتى المستشفيات التي سيتم تجهيزها
بأجهزة التنفس الصناعي والحاضنات
لهذا الغرض جاهزة لذلك
نحتاج فقط إلى الجانب الآخر لإحضارهم والأهم من ذلك
أننا جاهزون لاستقبال
10 ضرب 20 ضرب 30  أكثر من ذلك بكثير
نحن على استعداد للقيام بذلك، أعني أننا
موجودون في 37 مستشفى منزليًا، وقد
حددنا أكثر من 11000 سرير وأكثر من
1700 وحدة مركزية أكثر من آه، كما تعلمون، هناك 150
سيارة إسعاف جاهزة لنقل آه هؤلاء
المرضى لذلك قررنا أن نكرس جهودنا
وننشرهم  أكثر من 38.000 طبيب
و25.000 ممرض وممرض جاهزين
للعمل، لذا مهما كانت الأرقام التي
سنحصل عليها، فسنتعامل مع
لماذا لا تحصل على هذه الأرقام
لأنه يمكنك التعامل مع
عدد أكبر من المصابين؟  لن
تحصل عليهم مرة أخرى، الأمر
ليس قرار مصر، قرار مصر
هو
لا أعرف، لكن بالتأكيد هناك
شخص يجب عليه التحقق
ويجب عليه الإخلاء وإعطاء التصريح
لهؤلاء المرضى للخروج من هذه
الأراضي إلى  إلى الجانب المصري ولكني
أخبرتك أن فريقي وطاقمي
يبقون ليلًا ونهارًا في انتظار
دخول كل حالة لبدء التعامل
معهم، هل تعتقد أن إسرائيل لها
الكلمة الأخيرة بشأن المرضى الذين يخرجون
ليس لدي معلومات لأقولها  بخصوص
هذا لا أستطيع أن أقول شيئًا أستطيع لست
متأكدًا منه ولكن بالتأكيد
هناك أه سلطات معينة على
الجانب الآخر لاتخاذ قرارات بشأن من
سيخرج وإلا كان من الممكن أن
ننتظر قدوم آلاف المرضى
لأنه  لديهم
28000 مريض جاهز يمكننا أن نقول 10 20%
منهم أه يحتاج إلى
تدخلات مكثفة أه ليس لديهم هل
ستتمكن من استيعاب 28000 مريض
الآن النظام الصحي في مصر
يستوعب أكثر من 7080 مليون
مصري
لذلك لدينا  القدرة على
الاستيعاب وهذا من حيث
القدرة ولكن الأهم أه
الشغف الذي لدينا في
قلوب المصريين وفي قلب
مجتمعنا
وبقيادة رئيسنا الذي
يوجهنا منذ اليوم  واحد أنه
مهما كانت المرافق التي لدينا علينا
إحضارها وعلينا أن
نعطيها لأخواتنا
وإخوتنا وعائلاتنا من غزة لذا فإن الفكرة
هي أن النظام يمكن أن يستوعب بالتأكيد
نعم لذلك لكي نكون واضحين لا يوجد أساس أو
المعايير الموجودة فيما يتعلق
بقبول المرضى المصابين الفلسطينيين
بلا حدود بلا حدود، فكم عدد
سيارات الإسعاف الموجودة لديك على الحدود
الآن، كيف تدير أي
مريض يذهب إلى أين وما الذي
يتطلبه ذلك من منظور التخطيط واللوجستيات
لمصر؟
نقطة جيدة لأنني أخبرتك أننا
وضعنا أنفسنا على خطة الطوارئ أه
منذ اليوم الأول وأه نجلس
مع فريقنا وأه ونضع
الخطة مع أه منذ
البداية كما يجب على سيارة الإسعاف  نكون هناك
على الحدود ومن تلك النقطة لدينا
فرز ولدينا ثلاثة
مستشفيات في شمال سياي كمرحلة أولى
من المستشفيات ثم لدينا المرحلة الثانية
من المستشفيات في منطقة جنوب كندا
وهي بورت إس وسميا وسو أيضًا
كما هو الحال مع دومات وش مع
محافظنا المجاور، ستشرع مصر في إجراء
أي تحقيق فيما
يتعلق بأنواع الإصابات التي
كنت تراها، وأنا متأكد من أنك
تجمع البيانات في الوقت الحالي وفيما
يتعلق بكيفية ارتباط ذلك  بالنسبة للأسلحة
التي يتم استخدامها الآن داخل
غزة بالتأكيد يعني هذا أمر عادي جدًا
أن يكون لدينا متخصصون
وباحثون ومن مناطق مختلفة
لديهم عندما نشتبه في
الإصابة أو أه شيء نحتاج إلى
الحصول على المزيد من الأدلة العلمية أكثر
المعرفة حول ما يحدث، نفعل
ذلك طوال الوقت وهذا
شيء حتى نحصل على أدلة
ونحصل على دليل على ما رأيناه،
أعتقد أن هذا من السابق لأوانه التحدث عنه
أريد أن أتحدث عن أنواع الإصابات التي
تواجهها  لقد صادفت وما شاهدته
اليوم هو أنك تعرف صبيًا صغيرًا
وجسمه الصغير سبع إصابات
تتطلب تدخلًا من عدة
أطباء مختلفين، لذا أعطني ملخصًا
لما كنت تراه، أعني أن هذه
مجرد عينة مما رأيته  لكن أعني أن
لدينا حالات أه أعمق بكثير من جروح غرفة الطوارئ
مثل ما رأيته أعني أن
الإصابات تخرج من الشظايا
والحطام من الصواريخ آه، كما
تعلم، تصل إلى قاعدة كسر الدماغ في الجمجمة، وجروح
القطط العميقة
المخففة  كسور مفتوحة أه مفتوحة فقدان
الأنسجة كما ترون أم إصابات
الهياكل الحيوية أه التنسج الرباعي
أه بتر الليمفاويات
أشياء لا يمكنك رؤيتها في
حياتك الطبية العادية أه كما تعلم
وكما ذكرت تحتاج إلى
تخصصات متعددة  فرق للعمل معها
وهذا ما نقوم به من إجراء
الجراحة التجميلية مع جراح العظام
مع الاستشارة النفسية بالتأكيد أه كما
تعلم الاستشارة لأنك رأيت جزءًا
منهم وهم في حالة
صدمة عقلية